J.T. se suscribió
a un plan de mensajes de texto para su celular
con otros 3 miembros de su familia.
En cualquier mes no puede mandar
más de 500 mensajes de texto en total,
eso lo voy a subrayar
porque es importante,
no puede mandar
más de 500 mensajes de texto en total,
y ahora dice,
Al final del mes J. T. había mandado 25 mensajes más que su hermana mayor,
también lo voy a subrayar,
porque es un dato importante,
es una información importante,
había mandado 25 mensajes
más que su hermana mayor,
50 mensajes menos
que su hermana menor
y 125 más que su mamá,
la pregunta es
¿Cuántos mensajes de texto
pudo haber mandado J. T.
si no excedieron el límite
de los 500 mensajes de texto?
Entonces, ¿Cuántos mensajes de texto pudo
haber mandado J.T. si no excedieron el límite?
Ok, excelente ya tenemos aquí
la información que necesitamos,
lo subrayado es lo esencia.
y lo que vamos a hacer,
es definir algunas variables,
digamos qué "o"...
"o" es igual al número
de mensajes de texto
que hizo la hermana mayor,
entonces,
"o" es igual al número de mensajes de texto
de la hermana mayor,
y ahora, "y" es igual
al número de mensajes de texto...
mensajes de texto
de la hermana menor,
usaremos "m" de mamá,
entonces "m" es igual
al número de mensajes de texto...
"m" es igual
al número de mensajes de texto
de la mamá de J. T.
y ahora ya solamente falta J.T.,
entonces voy a definir a "j"
"j " es igual
al número de mensajes
por J. T.
y ¡ok!
El total de mensajes de texto
que todos se enviaron,
no pudo... no puede ser más que 500,
no puede exceder los 500.
Si sumamos los mensajes de "j"
más los de la hermana mayor,
más los de la hermana menor,
y más los de la mamá de J. T.,
la suma debe ser,
esta suma debe ser,
igual o menor que 500,
eso es importante,
debe ser menor o igual que 500,
tal vez si excede la cantidad de 500,
le cobren más o no lo sé, pero...
pero
¿Cómo, cómo podemos expresar
cada una de estas variables en términos
de la cantidad de mensajes que envió J.T.?
Aquí nos dan información,
dice que J.T. había mandado
25 mensajes más que su hermana mayor,
esto lo ponemos de esta manera "j" es igual a 25
más la cantidad de mensajes
que mandó su hermana mayor,
eso sería "o"
entonces "j",
es igual a 25 más "o"
y también nos dice que J. T. mandó 50 textos menos
que su hermana menor,
entonces,
"j" es igual a "y" menos 50,
y finalmente J.T. envío 125 mensajes
más que su mamá,
esto se pone de esta manera,
"j" es igual a "m" más 125,
y muy bien, queremos esta expresión
en términos de "j"
así que lo que voy a hacer para,
expresarlo en términos de "j"
es despejar cada una de las variables
la "o", la "y", la "m",
vamos a despejar esas, y ya,
sustituimos después de eso,
entonces hagamos esto,
hagamos esto,
si "j" es igual a 25 más "o"
simplemente vamos a restar
25 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
y obtenemos
"j" menos 25 es igual a "o"
simplemente restamos
25 de ambos lados.
Ahora vamos con el siguiente.
Sumamos 50,
aquí vamos a sumar 50
de ambos lados de la ecuación,
y lo que vamos a obtener es
"j" más 50 es igual a "y".
Finalmente,
lo que hacemos aquí es restar
125 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
obtenemos el número de mensajes
enviados por su mamá
entonces,
"m",
aquí restando 125 tenemos que
"j" menos 125 es igual a "m".
Entonces aquí lo que dice
es que J. T. envió
125 mensajes más
que su hermana mayor,
tomas la cantidad de mensajes
que envió J. T.,
restas 25 y obtienes
la cantidad de mensajes que envió la hermana mayor.
Ahora de igual manera envío
50 textos menos que su hermana menor,
tomas los mensajes que envió "j"
más 50 es igual a la cantidad
de mensajes que envió su hermana,
y para la mamá restas 125,
"j" menos 125 es igual a "m",
ahora si podemos sustituir
estas variables en la ecuación original.
Entonces tenemos "j" más "o"
pero "j" es igual a "j" menos 25
entonces voy a poner
"j" menos 25 aquí ,
"j" menos 25 más "y"
pero "y" es igual
a "j" más 50,
entonces pongo aquí,
voy a sustituir,
"j" más 50
y ahora "m",
entonces "m"
es igual a "j" menos 125,
más "j" menos 125,
todo esto debe ser
menor o igual que 500.
Ahora simplemente
vamos a sumar las "j"
tenemos
1, 2, 3, y 4j...
4j,
ahora vamos a sumar las constantes.
Tenemos -25... -25 más 50
esto es igual a 25 positivo
25 positivo menos 125
esto sería igual...
esto es igual a -100
entonces -100,
4j menos 100 es
menor o igual que 500.
Ahora vamos a
sumar de ambos
lados de la ecuación
sumamos
100 de ambos lados,
y obtenemos... esto se cancela,
obtenemos 4j es menor o igual que 600
dividimos ambos
lados de la ecuación entre 4
y obtenemos que "j",
aquí voy a ponerlo acá abajo,
"j" es menor o igual
que 150 y ahí lo tenemos,
Jt envió... envió...
150 mensajes o menos en este mes,
entonces de esa manera
las hermanas, J. T. y la mamá
enviaron 500 mensajes o menos.
Y no excedieron el límite
¡Muy bien! Nos vemos.